[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hello
let's talk about one of the most
important roles of an api program
in agile the api product owner
in agile the product owner is a central
role within the team
and the program from defining the
product to guiding the api team during
review of finished work
everything should be in the view of the
api product owner
a great venn diagram courtesy of henrik
neberg
positions the product owner role in the
middle of three responsibilities
build the right thing build the thing
right
and build it fast the scrum definition
of product owner
translates very well in the api contacts
the api product owner is a key
leadership role
when it comes to how api products should
be produced
and how it is being consumed upstream in
the digital value chain
the product owner needs to have a
connected and
empathic relationship with developers
experienced designers
and business leads that use the api
products to deliver on the experiences
for the customer the api product owner
also has to keep a handle on how the api
team is producing
api products and how they're connecting
into the backend systems of the
enterprise
the api product owner is often very busy
and the role can be quite challenging in
the context switching that is required
for example in the morning the product
owner may be speaking with digital
business leads to plan new experiences
that require
additional apis in the next release
later that morning the product owner
may be working with the scrum master and
api architect
to manage the backlog and prioritize
which stories are to be worked on
in the upcoming sprints in the afternoon
the product owner may be reviewing the
results of a recent
sprint and the apis with developers and
testers
in the last session of the day the
product owner is meeting with api
architects and
it leadership about potential changes
that need to be made downstream
to systems because the targets of the
back end have changed
what a day one of the key mindset traits
of product ownership
is to evangelize apis as truly products
the way the product owner drives the
communication
the packaging the documentation and
delivery of each api
will heavily influence how apis are
consumed and produced
this might manifest in the form of api
road shows
hackathons or building a really easy to
use and self-service developer portal
to summarize the role more concretely
the api product owner or po as often
called
is responsible for the following
defining and delivering value by making
decisions for the team on what's
more valuable defining the product
backlog
prioritizing the sprint backlog defining
requirements as well as the definition
of ready
and done and because of the
cross-functional demands a
background in product management and
web-based technology
is a key skill set the api product owner
has to be very involved in the
day-to-day sprint process
however depending on the size of the
organization and the number of apis
in the maturity of the api ecosystem
this might not always be feasible or
practical it's really important for the
product owner to recognize
when demands from people and teams
become too great for the hours a product
owner has available
this self-awareness is critical since
the product owner can often become
a bottleneck in the process in addition
since the api product owner also needs
to network
across the digital value chain for
upstream and downstream stakeholders
the scope can simply be too broad to go
deep with a development team
in these cases it is essential that the
product owner figures out
how and where to delegate authority one
such example
is in sprint refinement in refinement
sessions elaborating use cases
writing bdd use cases and collaborating
real time with the api architect
developers testers and scrum masters
really requires a pretty heavy focus and
time
if there are multiple api teams or
demands on building up the api program
buy-in
with business and it leadership this job
can be very intensive
the api product owner should bring on a
business analyst that can act as the
proxy to the product owner
it's important that the product owner
trains and transfers ownership and
decision making authority to the
business analyst
the businesses must have the authority
to make design
and requirement decisions if there are
certain thresholds that decisions cannot
be made
those lines also need to be made clear
looking more strategically
managing the backlog and the overall
product roadmap
is also a critical activity for the
product owner
however when it comes to backlog
management the api product owner may not
want to give up full authority to the
business analyst
certain priorities require
organizational perspective
to determine what should be in an api
release
these decisions may have many strategic
implications for the overall digital
transformation
and the overall api product roadmap in
orchestration with
upstream and downstream projects however
when it comes to the sequence in which
an api or user story
should be built within a sprint or
sprint by sprint
a business analyst in collaboration with
a scrum master and api architect
can make the decisions within the team
at the end of the sprint
the features developed should be up for
a group demonstration
this is called a sprint review or a
sprint demo
this demo could be to the team to the
end users like app developers
or with other interested business
stakeholders and executive sponsors
there are several motivations to demo or
do a review
they don't have to be all crammed into
one session and multiple demos might
make sense
scrum provides a framework and
guidelines but is up to each team
with the api product owner to discuss
and determine
what is the right audience and outcome
the product owner
should make the final decision on this
one as it relates
heavily to how the organization will
perceive the api program
here are some common reasons for our
sprint review these demos can be run by
executing on a postman
or a group file or create a simple web
app called to show how the api can be
used
to illustrate a visual example the one
thing we caution
against is to use the demo as a sign off
stage gate
demos are often too short to allow any
stakeholder a product owner or tester
to do a final acceptance furthermore
the time spent to orchestrate a demo and
qa at the same time can be very
inefficient used to the team's
collective time
all testing acceptance should happen
before the sprint review
if there isn't enough time don't rush
the sprinter view
and do it after the sprint is over focus
on the big picture
use the demo to garner excitement
celebrate accomplishments
and gather business feedback thank you
i hope this section helped you get a
deeper look
at the role of a product owner it's a
complex role
and each product owner we meet is
different and what you learn can be
adapted
and modified based on your style context
and organization
in addition the role can be split
between multiple people
owning different parts there's not just
one way
if you want more information please
check out the community
for ebooks articles and other related
topics
thank you again for watching